[Music]
hello welcome to our live Q&A on climate
change we'll be taking questions from
you for the next 20 or so minutes thanks
for being here
I'm Sarah I'm a video journalist at the
Economist and I'm here with Oliver
Morton who is one of our senior editors
here and also specializes in climate
science it has yes because we decided
some time ago to do a special issue on
the climate and this week we did it and
here it is and it's if I say so myself
really well the fine and this is the
first time am i right in thinking that
we've dedicated a whole issue to one
yeah yeah it's interesting um we at
Christmas we do a special jolly issue
with lots of interesting other stories
in it but we've never done as an issue
that's like devoted to one subject and
even this time what we've done and I
think this is I was I was very pleased
with what we decided to do we haven't
these these this issue isn't full of
only climate stories it's not sort of
like trying to be just a climate
catch-up yeah but we've taken climate
stories and given them prominence in
every single section of the paper so we
normally have I don't know 14 13
sections I think if you sort of like
spread it out a bit and all of those
deal with the whole world effectively or
bits of the world and because climate
matters for the whole world and all the
different bits of the world we went out
and made sure that we had good climate
stories that would be big stories in any
week and just made sure that we reported
them all in this week and so we put that
together with a big editorial and some
briefing that I put together and all
sorts other things but it means that you
know we have stories about the Panama
Canal and what will happen to it as
rainfall in Panama drops we have stories
about the mourning process for a glacier
in Iceland we have stories about tycoons
trying to make more money out of trying
to put climate change to rights
there are a whole range of different
things but all under the whole umbrella
of talking about the climate seriously
and urgent
and why we decided that now's the time
to do this well we wanted to do more
about climate for a while and we do it I
think we do do it well on a week-by-week
basis we wanted to make some sort of
climate ease splash and we came up with
this idea of climates or like running
through all the bits of the paper and
then we realized that if we're going to
do that we might as well do it at a time
when people wouldn't climate was on
people's minds and this is a time when
climate is on people's minds very much
and the cover is striking sure this is
an idea from my matches you're
interesting um this is a visualization
and it's showing you every year from the
middle of the nineteenth century to now
and the colors represent the difference
in temperature between that year and an
average temperature which has taken some
time in the middle 20th century so what
you see is in the nineteenth century
it's cooler and the breaks of dark blue
and there's not much pattern through
most of it but then towards the end you
start noticing that it's going really
red and this this is a strategy that was
invented by a really smart climate
scientist at the University of Reading
ed Hawkins who's looked at various ways
of visualizing science and particularly
rising climate science as well as doing
other fun things like trying to get
people to read log books form 19th
century ships so that we can get more
climate data on the 19th century it came
up with this idea it's been around a
fair bit online and elsewhere some
people have it on ties we thought it
would just be a great way to show that
this is about everything rather than
having an image of one particular
effective climate this was a way of sort
of like saying the whole thing and it
helps that you know it's a striking
image and this we've also put up a film
looking at what trees can do to change
if you want to watch that you can click
on the I in the top right hand corner of
the screen and we're going to go through
questions from the community tab also
taking questions live so please do send
them in if you have any yeah so world
leaders are gathering in New York for
the UN
climate action summit to discuss what
can be done to reach Net Zero emissions
by 2050 and millions around the world
are hitting the streets to protest today
for urgent actions and so we've had lots
of questions from people asking just how
bad climate change is there's a lot of
misunderstanding around it our first
question is from Milan Prasad and he
asked what are the long-term
implications of rapid decline in polar
icecaps
ah well the problem with climate change
when you're talking about how bad is it
is this really nothing to compare it to
there's nothing else that humans come up
against that takes centuries and
profoundly reshapes
the planet so for ice caps if the ice
caps stuck well the two things we've got
remember the floating ice which you have
mostly in the Arctic and you have ice
that's on armed continents and islands
which you have in both the Arctic and
the Antarctic
if the ice on Antarctica or Greenland
starts to flow off it very fast and
dynamic shifts to that ice so you might
see enough melting this century to see
sea levels rise by 1 or maybe even 1.5
meters which would be huge compared to
anything we've seen historically if it's
more slow then it may might be sort of
like more like 80 centimeters but at the
moment sea level rise is dominated by
the fact that the when you warm up water
it expands and by the melting of
glaciers on land but as this century
goes on I think it's fair to say that
the melting of ice in the Arctic ice on
land in the Arctic is going to be a big
factor in that and of course that's what
it means to someone like me who lives
near the Thames Estuary in London in the
Arctic it means your entire world is
changing really rapidly all the ways
that animals behave at all though the
habitats for animals are changing that
doesn't mean they're all going extinct
but it means that there are new stresses
on them and on how they interact with
people the permafrost is melting which
means that in the Arctic a lot of
foundations are in permafrost so
everything goes a bit higgledy-piggledy
and you know ways of life are changing
really rapidly because the Arctic warms
much faster than the rest of the
really interesting and we have a piece
on ice caps we did we have a and we also
have a piece about the question of some
people in Russia thinking that hey so be
a little bit warmer that sounds kind of
good and looking at how that kind of
good sounding thing compares to the
other things that Russia is facing in a
warmer world and it's true to say that
climate change touches everything and
everyone but the impacts of warming
temperatures is different depending on
where you are in the world and so Omar
Ahmed asked how has climate change
affected third world countries it's
really hard to tell - again to pull out
the signal of climate change so far from
other things is a really tricky problem
but in general if you are stressed by
climate change in the agricultural
sector then that makes it much harder to
do the things that we know that
successfully developing countries have
done in the past of so I can proving a
cure agricultural efficiency
urbanization things like that and there
are some places where rain patterns are
already changing a bit and you don't
know yet whether that's of variation in
normal climate or climate change but you
absolutely know that rainfall patterns
around the tropics will change quite a
lot our Nino frequences will probably
change which will change the the
patterns of drought and of flooding so
we've seen large floods already
for instance in Mozambique it's all much
harder if you don't have any resources
to adapt to it and if you don't have any
resources to adapt to it it hits you
were so you don't build up the resources
to adapt in the future so there's a
there's a vicious circle here which kind
of undermines an awful lot of what else
is being done mostly by developing
countries but also to some extent by the
world community to hit the UN
sustainable development goals it's much
harder to do that if the climate isn't
the one that you're used to and is
actively it seems working against you
and we should also mention that we have
a great peace in the Middle East in
Africa section on how rising
temperatures are making it even harder
to reduce poverty in Malawi that's
certainly true yes it's a case example
of that yeah
on to the next question Matt Cruz asked
how soon can we expect climate change to
have a major detrimental impact on the
global economy if only you had this the
right way of running the world with
climate change and without climate
change except that if you did have that
you just run it without climate change
so it's hard to be out it's very hard on
this one okay listen
climate change is a very complicated
thing which doesn't mean people don't
know quite all about it and no that's
going to be bad but quantifying it is
really difficult there are different
approaches to measuring the economic
impacts of climate change that give you
really quite different answers and the
other thing is there's much less impact
if you do more now than if you don't do
more now so these are all things which
are relative to uncertainties both about
how the economy works about how nature
works and about what choices political
entities nations and nations mainly make
about this and so at the moment you
can't point to anything and say you can
look point to the economic costs of
something like a hurricane but you can't
point to anything and say you know that
that that percentage point of world GDP
that that was because of climate in the
long run you can look at 3 4 5 percent
of world GDP in various different
projections but I think I think that in
the end though the economics of how one
tackles climate change are really
important looking for an economic reason
of an economic output from the climate
change itself is not necessarily the
best way of seeing it even though that I
do believe that economic change is there
someone we mentioned there protesters
out today and a lot of young students
we know that many of them believe that
the only way to tackle climate change is
by uprooting capitalism what would you
say to that unsurprisingly The Economist
is is not in favor of the uprooting of
capitalism at the same time if
capitalism can't do a better job of
responding to this crisis there
claims that other systems can do better
will get stronger and stronger so I
think this is it's bull remember climate
check that the fossil fuels are
absolutely built into the same period of
history that has seen the rise of
capitalism throughout the world and
there is a view that without fossil
fuels you couldn't have had that sort of
extraordinary growth in growth in income
growth in wealth creation growth in
simple numbers of people that may indeed
be true that doesn't necessarily mean
that you have to change the system when
you get rid of the fuels but it doesn't
mean that it's a genuine question about
how hard you try to do that I think this
is one you're only going to be able to
answer going backwards I hope that
liberal democracies with systems like
the liberal democracies now use are able
to respond to this well and I think that
they really have to try harder if
they're going to convince the rest of
the world of that and we're gonna have a
look at some of their live questions now
people who are sending them in right now
there's one from a Nepal Mishra who says
is there a need to change eating habits
to tackle climate change if you can
change a lot of people's eating habits
then that will make a difference the
problem is that if you check that
changing your habits doesn't necessarily
change other people's habits and forcing
people to change the way they eat is
hard to do in a liberal way and
obviously quite unpopular if the whole
world at a lot less meat then given the
way that people now farm there would be
like considerably lower emissions from
agriculture now it may be possible to
lower the emissions from agriculture in
other ways there may also for many
people be reasons not associated with
the climate why they don't like the
suffering of animals that get eaten
brilliant and we're now moving on to
what people can do what it's done quite
nicely so a few of you on the community
tab had questions about what you could
do as individuals and one of you even
asked what activities your College
Environmental Protection Club could do
and
and Amit DAF asked what measures should
an individual take to reverse the
effects of climate change what do you
think vote for people who want to do
that most of climate change is a systems
problem there's lots of stuff you can do
that will make your own personal
contribution less but you are one of
seven and a half billion people and
that's that's a terrible problem because
people obviously want to do things and
in most environmental situations there
are things that individuals can do and
there are ways that you can lower your
own individual carbon footprint and that
can give you a genuine benefit in
feeling that you are not making other
people's lives worse but you're not
actually making them better the way to
make them better is to act politically
to try and get the systems the ways
energy is generated and things like that
change that said I personally fly less
than I used to though I still fly
considerably more than the average
person in Britain and far more than the
average person around the world but I
try to fly on work-related things across
continents I try not to fly within
Europe but that's a pretty privileged
position because I can sort of like
afford or get other people to afford to
pay for me to take trains which are
often more expensive yeah I noticed that
you tweeted once about the hashtag
flight change yeah no I well I think
that I think that it's I think given the
fact that I write a lot about climate
both at the Economist not written books
have been of the kind of about carbon
and climate it's not so much that I'm
ashamed of flying but I felt that there
was a I felt that given the way that
people are thinking about this better
and more critically I felt that it was
useful for me to be transparent about it
so when I fly I now tend to tweet that
I've flown and how much carbon is
involved and what offset I've used to
sell my conscience now some people say
well look the plane flew anyway so you
know you didn't really achieve anything
I didn't but if a more people think like
this then eventually there
we'll be a lower demand for air travel
perhaps I don't know that that's the
case
so I'm I'm in the same position as a lot
of other people I slightly I worry that
I'm part of the problem which I
undoubtedly am I know that I can be I
mean I'm reasonably sure that by
contributing to my colleagues work in
this issue which i think is terrific
I've probably done a great deal more
than a void of flight to Copenhagen but
you know you do what you do what you can
and you do and it's about thinking about
it as well as what you actually do if it
builds into your thinking about the
world that planes are linked to the
climate that's an important thing to do
we've actually just had a live question
in about transport into that so patrick
de Jong said do you consider electric
cars a good idea to tackle climate
change yes but there's a there's a
important proviso electric cars are good
especially and particularly when the
grid that's feeding them is good if
you're just making your electricity with
coal over there and then using in a car
over here that may or may not be
depending on your pattern of driving the
may or may not be efficiency gains but
if you can make the electric grid much
much greener which we frankly know how
to do then yes making a using electric
cars better it's not an environmental
panacea but it definitely is going to be
I think a big part of how we change
transportation I personally don't drive
but that's more because I've got
hand-eye coordination problems in a bad
temper and also I live in a place with
great public's public transport if I did
Drive I would almost certainly by now be
buying a hybrid electric car and another
live question we've just had in what do
you think about some of the young people
who are striking today saying they're
not planning to have children because of
the fear of climate change that's my
personal isn't it I don't have children
but that's not because of fear of
climate change I think that it's
probably not the thing you should be
thinking about most because I do hear a
lot of young people who seem to me to
have an exaggerated idea of the personal
effect
of near-term climate change on them
themselves
climate change is mostly as the IPCC
points out a problem for poor people and
marginalized people in developing
countries it's a problem elsewhere as
well and it will get worse and worse and
I have no doubt that it could get very
bad indeed I'm not sure that you should
build your entire life on a fear of the
future not least because you then
slightly again as someone childless
owned I feel I feel about telling anyone
else what to do but you kind of slightly
reduce your stakes in the game right if
you're if you're saying well it's all
gonna go to [ __ ] and we're going to and
everything's gonna die that's you may
really want to do something about it but
you've slightly taken your take it
taking your finger off the pulse I so I
would say make choices about how to have
children on the basis of what you want
and what people you love want and what
you think the world what what role you
think those children can play in the
world that would be my general advice
and we have another request a question
from the community tab subordinate and
can we reverse climate change is it
possible to reverse climate change it's
possible in theory in the long term to
change the climate in other ways that
make things colder that's not quite the
same as reversing climate change so it's
conceivable that using various forms of
technology you might suck all the carbon
dioxide that humans have emitted back
out of the atmosphere over the next 500
years or 300 years rather than have it
stick around for 10,000 years
so that's conceivable that's not that's
not like saying reversing it's not quite
reversing climate change though because
it's not like the world will never have
been heated up it's just that all have
heated up and cooled down again and so a
lot of the effects such as the people
who had to move away from the shorelines
or the things that have gone extinct now
actually have friends who want to bring
back extinct animals but that's
different story it's that that past
doesn't go away the suffering that
people undergo doesn't go away similarly
there are ideas which I've actually
written a book about about trying to
limit the amount of sunlight that comes
into the earth system so that the
warming is not so intense not as an
alternative to reducing greenhouse gas
emissions but as a way of reducing some
of the harm that goes on before those
reductions get well underway again
though that's not reverse that's that's
another climate change which you think
might be a bit better and which would
have its own complicated political
outcomes so you can't there's no off
switch it's really difficult but the
idea that once the climate has changed
for the worst it can never ever ever get
any better as one I think you should
probably resist and we should mention
that on our cover a few weeks ago we had
deforestation we do Amazon rainforest
which is accelerating and we know now
that it could be approaching a tipping
point which there's no going back we had
a film at this week about trees and
climate change and if you want to watch
that you can just click on the I in the
top right hand corner of the screen on
to the next question
Kyle watt asked this is from the
community tab letter land used to plant
trees or land use with solar panels can
you Oh people have actually tried to
quantify that quite a lot
it depends what I mean putting solar
panels on is really useful if you are
replacing other electricity that's being
made in a dirty way so that's great or
if you're providing people with
electricity who otherwise would not have
any electricity and want electricity
like you know well over a billion people
around the world then they will say this
piece of land near me please put solar
panels on it and I think that'll be the
right thing to do you shouldn't build
solar panels just for the hell of it
though and there are some places where
which aren't well suited to solar solar
energy where it might make more sense to
to plant trees in general though what
the great thing about solar panels is
the more of them we put out the cheaper
the next one's become with
this learning principle whereby the more
solar panels we produce the cheaper they
become this is not true of trees trees
are very cheap but they will always be
basically the same thing so at the
moment if your solar panel replaces
coal-fired power absolutely if it adds
part of people who need power yes if
you're just doing it for bling I don't
really think anyone is or just a farm
subsidy then you know trees are nice I
do think that by and large trees are
prettier than solar panels and any
conversation about land you know land
has a finite resource there is an issue
with space yeah any decision about what
to do with a piece of land you're not
doing something else one of the reasons
why some people especially people people
you know quite a lot of supposedly green
energy low emissions energy is biomass
energy and that's why there are some
people who are very interested in the
idea growing more biomass at sea where
by and large no one wants to live and
one of the advantages is that if you can
encourage the biomass at sea you might
also encourage you'll get to like
secondary benefits in terms of fish
populations and things like that so kelp
is also part of the story as well as
trees there's clearly growing public
will for something to be done but a lot
of the people on our community tab we're
interested in whether policy you can
make a difference especially top of
course this week is the UN climate
action summit in New York
M'Lynn Prasad asked have international
bodies figured out any strict measures
against countries destroying their
forest cover and biosphere reserves no
they haven't and there's a there's a
rough-and-ready rule in international
relations you can have strict measures
on small things or you can have that
apply to a small group of countries and
you can only have very loose measures on
large things and in climate we're mostly
on that because you can't in the
international community is not willing
to go to war to take the most extreme
example in order to save or save a bit
of nature now you can put pressure and
you've seen this in you've seen this in
Brazil but Olga as so with questions
about trade with the EU and whether new
EU trade trade agreements would be
subject to
would be put in put at risk by
continuing deforestation that's that's I
think a legitimate tactic at the moment
there's no concerted global way of doing
that sort of thing it's a bit sore like
case by case yeah I Anne Malik said
popular leaders like Donald Trump and
balsa narrow design deny the existence
of climate change how do you combat this
narrative interesting I don't think
don't Trump as a particular popular
leader I mean it's his ratings and the
opinion polls are sort of like not
particularly high yeah there's not much
you can do to such leaders they
obviously think I don't know I don't
think if I don't know if I really want
to get into second guessing what people
think I don't think there's any
remaining shred of credible evidence for
standing on the position that humans
aren't causing climate change if you're
doing that you're doing it either
because you're ignorant or because you
actually have another agenda and if and
so I guess the answer is to tackle them
on the other gender the other answer of
course is to vote against them in your
briefing paper this week you wrote about
how one of the challenges is that this
is a collective action problem on a
geopolitical level can you talk a bit
about that and just laying why that's
problematic there's this big problem
that what happens to the climate in your
country depends what everybody depends
on what everybody does so if you reduce
your carbon emissions by a great deal
and put a huge amount of effort into it
and well terribly hard on it and no one
else does you don't get a better world
you just have you've just done something
that has done it's a bit like the
situation just of the individual frankly
that you know if you do your thing you
might feel better about it but you
haven't changed the world so there's a
great incentive on countries to have
other people do stuff and because if
someone out if everyone else does stuff
and you don't then you
get all the benefit without having put
in any of the work and that's what in
game theory they call a collective
action problem and it's a real problem I
think in climate change diplomas I mean
David Victor whose fungal breakfasts on
this I think would say it's the biggest
problem in international agreements on
climate change that you can't find a way
in reference to that earlier question
about deforestation you don't really
nations don't have ways of forcing each
other to do things against their
interests and most people who live in
most nations kind of like this they kind
of like the idea that people elsewhere I
can't tell them what to do and so when
everyone has to do the same thing but no
one has to necessarily go first do you
do get this this what's this stalling
problem now there is one thing though to
make maybe make it feel a bit better
about this maybe makes me feel a bit
better about this Britain is reducing
its carbon emissions and you know has
reduced its carbon emissions down to the
level of the late nineteenth century
which is kind of amazing partly by
developing offshore windfarms now when
it started off offshore windfarms were
extremely expensive I mean I watering
lis expensive but as a mixture of
subsidies genuine demand and pretty well
directed technological improvement that
was done by industry yeah but also to
some extent by government means that the
price subsidy for those wind farms has
plummeted and we saw the new round of
British wind farms announced today and
they are you know sort of like four
times less there's four times less
substitute Omega well maybe what
happened there was when they started off
so that's kind of kind of amazing now I
you can find people in Britain and new
officer counties say well we're still
paying more for that energy than we
would be if we were burning gas and
that's absolutely true the good thing
here is that the next generation of
other nations that go for offshore wind
power will start with the sort of
technology that Britain has got to now
some people may say that didn't want to
develop technology for other people just
as some people in Germany may say that
you know we've paid an awful lot of
subsidies on solar panels to make them
cheaper
everyone else but that is one of the
ways that cleaner technologies get cheap
enough to use great and we've got one
last question from the community tab
which is is the green New Deal enough to
stop the climate crisis the u.s. lead
note looks at Democratic candidates big
plans to deal with climate change goes
back to age of the collective active
their collective action problem
noting that any given nation does
response the problem at the level of the
planet America is a big emitter but it's
not the biggest emitter and if it were
to radically reduce its emissions that
would be a little bit good but it
doesn't solve the problem at the level
of the planet the green new deal isn't
really as yet a policy it's a sort of
like space into which policies might fit
to achieve some sort like overarching
some overarching radical reduction
there's a strong view that by running
climate in with a lot of other issues
the green New Deal a plays into
Republican hands about what what it is
that green politics really is and it's
all about redistribution and things like
that and also there's a worry that it
sort of diffuses the energy around
climate specifically at the same time I
think it's absolutely clear that
American climate policy could be
considerably more ambitious and I'm kind
of glad that people are talking about
more ambitious ways into it sometimes
societies have to have big disagreements
and someone has to win and someone has
to lose all you were running out of time
so I just want to ask you briefly is
there anything to be optimistic about
I'm really terrible on the optimism
question because I'm kind of like so
like grumpy and pessimistic myself
there's something about being optimistic
that there are definitely ways to have
less harm and more harm and we know a
lot of things that can reduce the harm
helping people in developing countries
adapt to the climate they already facing
reduces harm reducing emissions through
government action and through other
means reduces harm in the long run can
this be magical stuff can it be solved
as quickly as people in extinction
rebellion and lots of the young people
out demonstrating today are demanding no
I honestly don't think it can I think
that there's a lot of climate change
that's probably just going to happen but
that still means that you couldn't
protect people against the worst bits of
it and do things to reduce how bad it
gets so the you don't often hear Italian
communists quoted at the Economist but
the Italian Congress gram she wrote from
his prison Diaries that you must strive
for pessimism of the intellect but
optimism of the will
I'd say use the intellect to inform the
will and try and find things you can
improve and then I think you can you've
earned a bit of optimism but you can't
just have it for free great note to end
will wrap it up there and if you want to
find out more then click on the I in the
top right hand corner of the screen next
week we've got a film coming out about
how climate change is shaking up the
insurance industry so keep an eye out
for that don't forget to Like and
subscribe thanks so much for joining us
Olly
my pleasure thank you for watching
you